how to prevent people from stealing your
idea so I got a great question for our
YouTube viewers love you guys Michael
who wrote in to ask what if you have a
sex toy I have a provisional patent on a
sex toy I'm finalizing utility patent as
we speak my question is how do we
prevent them from stealing or taking
your idea the recent masters I have a
wife that doesn't work I have $2.00 six
and three months and I'm finishing up my
computer science degree
I lost my retirement I got to start all
over again how do I connect with you how
do I get in the adult toy industry he
wants to get this thing out so how do
you do it so this is a great question
and Michael you already on your way here
the best way to protect your idea you
have two options one is a patent so
nobody can copy exactly what you're
doing or you go with trade secrets and
that's more like coca-cola you have a
special recipe you have a special way of
doing things that you don't want to be
made public knowledge and you see
lasting for hundreds of years so the
patent is a great way to go the thing
with patents okay this is important to
remember you have to be willing to do
more than just create a patent because
the patent costs money and looking at
your situation you don't have a lot of
money right so you need to not just
create a patent if you're gonna decide
this is what I'm gonna do with my life I
want this sex toy to be the greatest
thing ever then you need to be willing
to go beyond just making a patent you
have to get this thing out there I
remember going to an inventors
conference that I was speaking at and
one of the speaker's was talking about a
toothbrush a toothbrush that had
toothpaste inside the handle and you
press the button and the toothpaste came
up through the bristles and it came up
as you're brushing your teeth
so it's like a toothpaste and toothbrush
all-in-one and there were hundreds of
different patents for this kind of idea
hundreds of patents that are out there
have you actually seen going to market
how many successful toothbrushes have
you seen where the toothpaste is
somewhere in the handle I haven't seen
it I haven't seen any and so the point
is is a lot of patents there's a lot of
patents out
and most of them are just junk patents
because the inventors don't do anything
with them it's not enough to have just a
patent you waste your time and money on
this thing for what you have to get out
there and commercialize it you have to
build a marketing engine you have to
create a movement around it and if it's
not you who's gonna do it you have to
partner up with people who will one of
my best suggestions if you're going down
the patent route is to partner up with
your lawyer okay a lawyer a law firm
they're not making a lot of money off of
you right you're going them to them for
one patent they know your
budget-conscious they're not making a
lot of money off for you
the companies are making money off of
are the huge companies the companies who
you want to sell your product into right
now your product I'm assuming is
game-changing it's gotta be you want
companies the license it from you has
got to be something special it's gotta
be something nobody has done before
something that's really gonna take off
in the market but the law firms those
big clients they could get big Billings
from them and I would try to structure
deal with a law firm who has connections
into those companies to either do the
patent for you for free or at a
massively reduced cost and give them a
piece of the upside and have them help
you make the introductions to the
companies that's how you can partner up
to sell this thing in you could try to
do it yourself
but it depends on what you want to do
with your life right you want to be the
inventor or you want to build a company
there are two different things but you
have to do more than just get the patent
you've got your provisional patent it's
gonna run out you need to start paying
for your patent you got to pay a lawyer
to do it and you got to pay annual
maintenance fees for each country man
that gets expensive so you have to
decide where you want to take this
who are you gonna partner up with and
how are you gonna build your movement
and your marketing machine to turn this
idea into a game-changing
revenue-producing
adult toy industry smashing product
believe those be watching you liked the
video give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think please leave a
comment underneath ask me a question
I'll make a video response and if you
want to see more videos like this click
on my face subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you soon